all right it's Wednesday the day you've
all been waiting for we're going to
reveal what this critter was from last
week and introduce a new guy so very few
of you got this right people were
complaining that the past ones were too
easy so I did a little bit of a harder
one and it was yeah it was pretty tricky
a lot of people said that they think
this is some sort of a mustelid
and that's very 1996 of you in 1997 this
animals actually moved out of the
mustelid family we had suspected for
quite a while this wasn't a true
mustelid by the way mustelids are
weasels and otters and you know those
types of critters this animal used to be
thought to be closely related to those
guys
and it is fairly closely related but not
as close not close enough to be included
in that family so in 1997 it was really
a scientific consensus was strong enough
that it was pulled out into its own
group this is a skunk and my fighted so
skunks and stink badgers are now on
their own family and yeah good work
there were a couple of you who got that
right but very few of you again mustelid
was close but not correct so
congratulations to those few of you who
got that right your names are in the
video description so moving on to
today's guest another small guy and
another I think it's a tricky one I'm
curious to see how well people do with
this
check out this strange little creature
what on earth could that be
never mind the upside down 21 written on
its jaw
this is on
from cintamani Wildlife Center the skull
a really really neat little specimen
a couple things worth noting
it does not have any canine teeth but
it's got molars it's got two incisors on
the bottom if we can get that to focus
real nicely there two incisors on the
bottom two chisel like incisors
and on the top the top is really
interesting it looks if you look at it
straight on and it looks like there's
four drink it to the focus there we go
if you look at it straight on it looks
like there's four incisors they're
actually not there's just two incisors
in the front there and there's a line
down the middle of them a grooved in the
middle but behind those incisors there's
another set of incisors so we do have
four total incisors on the front and
again they're chisel like at that
really fascinating teeth on this guy
this is probably one of mind this skull
to be really creepy looking which I
actually don't find most skulls to be
creepy I find most schools to be
beautiful with this one I mean this is
beautiful too but also and it kind of
it's got a creepy vibe that it gives off
when I look at it just the way that my
brain interprets this thing and I think
one of the reasons that I'm so I get so
creeped out by this skull compared to
other skulls is because it looks so
incredibly different from the animal
when it's alive
this animal when it's alive is actually
really yeah it's different looking and I
want to give away too much by describing
what it's like when it's alive but
yes I find this school to be a little
bit creepy which is unusual for me
I guess a lot of people find skulls to
be creepy but I just find them to be
normally find them to just be
fascinating
yeah what do you think this critter
could be is it as Chewbacca bruh
is it a alien-human hybrid is it
radioactive mole what is it what is this
strange bizarre creature with its four
incisors on the top two on the bottom
don't google it it's against the rules
so very curious to see how many of you
get this correct five years ago before I
really started working with animals at
the Shan timony Wildlife Center this
would have been an absolute mystery to
me
one other thing to look is it's kind of
cool what this specimen is it's got the
the ear bones point upward and backward
which is interesting it's actually got
ossified tubes there most mammals have
ears that did go up from behind there
but the the tube is not usually ossified
like this so I think that's kind of a
cool structure on this skull so yes what
is this mystery creature find out next
week on what's it Wednesday